how's it going everybody it's Warren and
it's a good day because we have some
more information about Avengers in game
yesterday Disney and Marvel Studios
invited some of the press over to their
lot in Burbank California where they
screened some of Avengers in game they
screened two scenes and one of the
scenes was the footage that was shown at
CinemaCon that I did a video on a couple
of days ago and that was the same
footage that was shown at the Disney
shareholders meeting but they did show
some new footage and it was of the
beginning of Avengers in game now
obviously the press that were there
signed in DA's and can't just go online
and leak what they saw however we do
know a little bit about the footage and
how the press all reacted to the footage
I'll talk about it and break it all down
in this video but first if you're new to
my channel be sure to subscribe
I do monthly giveaways right now I'm
giving away a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet and a painting of Thanos by
globe by beau all you have to do to
enter is be subscribed to my channel
like the video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain so as I mentioned
the new scene that was shown was of Tony
Stark and nebula both aboard the Benatar
everybody that was in attendance
reported that the Russo brothers gave
them no context about what was shown but
everybody believes that this scene takes
place very early on in the movie Brandon
Davis who was a writer for comic book
calm shared everything that he was
allowed to share about the scene that he
saw and this is what he said first of
all Tony Stark and nebula make for an
interesting team ironically one is made
of metal parts and the other became
famous for wearing a metal suit their
personalities however could not be more
different as one operates with
machine-like tendencies and an
aggressive attitude and the other has
trouble taking anything seriously as
seen in the trailers for Avengers in
game the two will do some tinkering and
have their share of desperate moments
but the clip shown offered up something
different while the situation in which
Tony and nebula find themselves in sends
a clear message of hopelessness and
desperation they found solace in a
simple homemade tabletop game to pass
the time they might even be bonding a
little bit that's what this movie seems
to be about the idea of individuals
coming together to be greater than the
sum of their parts so that's all that
Brandon Davis could say about the
footage that was shown to the press by
Disney it sounds like Tony Stark and
nebula are going to have an interesting
dynamic
it sounds like the two of them will
clash in the beginning which makes sense
because they are both very different
people but as they continue to be
stranded and hopelessness and
desperation kicks in they start to bond
with each other they get to a point
where there is no hope left but they
find solace in a tabletop game that's on
the ship the two of them end up bonding
and ultimately decide that they don't
want to remain stranded in space and
they start tinkering around with the
ship to figure out a way to get them
back home which is what we see in the
trailers that have already been released
everybody that was in attendance
reported that the footage that they saw
was amazing however many of them
reported that they were left with more
questions than they had going in to
seeing the footage so it does appear
like we truly do not have any idea of
what's going to happen in Avengers
endgame so that's it for the new
Avengers in game footage that was shown
to the press by Disney and Marvel
Studios if any more new information
about these scenes that were shown comes
out I'll be sure to let you all know but
let me know what you all think about
this new scene that was shown with Tony
Stark and nebula let me know in the
comments down below and again if you're
new don't forget to subscribe comment
down below and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
on everything relating to Avengers in
game in all things Marvel as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]